[Música]
boa noite a todos
tudo bem mas empolgação pessoal boa
noite a todos
a gente fica tremendo ansioso ea gente
dá um boa noite pessoal
boa noite quando animada também a gente
também não é
antes de começar minha história eu
preciso contar a história da minha mãe e
do meu pai
dona mercedes isso josé barbosa
eles vieram de minas gerais para tentar
uma vida boa que em são paulo há uma
emprego mas quando chegou aqui como
milhões de pessoas se depararam com a
situação negativa e aí foi morar na casa
de parentes
e a gente sabe que quando a gente mora
na casa de parente tem um prazo de
validade né
daqui a pouco ninguém fica curto cani já
o emprego quando é que você vai sair e
aí e se com a situação da minha família
então meu pai fica sabendo que na região
do jardim ibirapuera na zona sul de são
paulo está tendo uma ocupação um terreno
da prefeitura e aí eles chegam lá e meu
pai consegue esse pedacinho de terra
nem a gente constrói nosso primeiro
baque na nossa primeira mudança e aí
chegando lá né vai montar 24 e tal
nessa época era o meu irmão ea minha
irmã e eu ainda era um projetinho de
vida ainda na conta dos meus pais e em
nasce o rio e até trabalho para seguir
foi uma confusão danada vai ter não vai
esse menino vem nuvem
então ea gente constitui a nossa família
em timor onde passou por muita
dificuldade e ali no jardim ibirapuera
então a minha família questão do emprego
questão é da moradia morando barquinho
de madeira e aí a gente nossa casa foi a
última casa a ser construída então tinha
aquela dificuldade mesmo de tipo de
alimento é meu pai saía para trabalhar
não conseguir emprego
a mãe também não então é aí a gente
decidimos que ele eles decidiram que o
meu pai a trabalhar minha mãe cuida da
família mas não deu certo
então quando o rapaz e assim mudar a
aiea se mudar para algum lugar e aí a
gente tem a nossa primeira mudança
extraordinária em processos é o troco
meu barraco quando se o tal que eu vou
levar minha família total
meu pai é uma beleza a gente se muda um
pouquinho pra cima da rua foi o porteiro
já valorizou um pouco na favela quando
você melhora um pouquinho terreno
valorizando também e aí só que com isso
também o meu pai e começou a beber muito
e aí às vezes as pessoas pegavam falar
com o irmão minha irmã vai lá buscar o
seu pai que ele está caído no chão e aí
os meus irmãos em tinha muita vergonha
disso
e aí quando quando não era contrário ele
chegava bêbado quebrando tudo dentro de
casa e já quebravam que a gente não
tinha né
então é complicado já chegava tal é o
pior de tudo ele começou a agredir a
minha mãe
e aí durante 15 anos com seis para 15
anos eu acompanhei todo esse processo de
agressão e aí eu senti uma raiva muito
grande no meu pai tio foi criando um
ódio dentro do meu coração e eu até aos
16 anos eu vivi com o com isso e quando
eu ia para a escola eu já ia me
revoltado roupa doada é que as pessoas
doavam a roupa tal e é uma molecada como
estava a tirar um barato porque minha
roupinha era velha né
e aí eu peguei e falei beleza ficava
bravo chegava em casa chateado e na
época tinha querido comentará os jackson
five já se levanta a mão
pouca gente ninguém da minha época
então e os jackson five está aí não
tinha dinheiro pra cortar o cabelo já
tinham black natural já o black era
natural zinho já e aí resolvi é sair da
escola e aí com 12 para 13 anos eu
evento de
um amigo meu falou ali comigo ali patauá
e fumar um baseado falei então como a
não saber como é que é esse troço tal é
quem adivinha quem sou eu nessa foto aí
do lado esquerdo com um copo na mão do
baixinho enjoado né
só o chassi do grilo complicado então e
aí fiquei durante 14 anos nas drogas
isso pra mim foi tudo é conseqüência da
questão familiar né das brigas dentro de
casa e aí comecei em primeiro com
maconha cocaína aí daqui a pouco bebida
daqui a pouco já estava no mês claro que
é maconha com pedra
não sei se alguém já ouviu falar já e e
um dia eu parei e falei nossa eu fiz uma
reflexão da minha vida nossa tô pior que
o meu pai
pelo menos no meu pai e ele bebia e né
das loucuras de lá só quem é essa raiva
milan ficou tão forte dentro do meu
coração que eu acabei me tornando pior
que o meu pai então um dia eu estava
encostado na rua lá no canindé com
alguns amigos meu e aí passou um carro
20 metros depois um cara eu conhecia
dentro do carro e aí desce dois caras
que eu não conhecia e aí um deles pegou
chegou estava aí mas alguns amigos ele
falou assim ah dá licença que se ninguém
aqui é safado e aí me deu uma paulada e
aí pegou na minha mão onde eu tenho uma
marca até hoje
e aí eu nunca escutei minha mãe sempre
foi aquele moleque né
é complicado tal sempre uns lá adiante
também tipo eu sempre gostei de ser
jogador de futebol então o negócio é
jogar futebol
tá na rua correndo tal com a molecada
fazendo bagunça já tinha saído da escola
fica na rua você é jogador de futebol
mesmo né
nunca pensei no plano b da minha vida e
quando isso aconteceu comigo aí eu
comecei a correr na hora lembrei de tudo
o que minha mãe me falou que me amava
que queria meu bem
e aí eu falei eu comecei em construir um
cantinho comecei a chorar e aí eu falei
nossa como minha vida é hoje então
depois o usuário de droga reconhecida
naquele momento estou apanhando sem ter
feito nada e aí eu peguei esse nosso é
preciso mudar minha vida não posso
continuar desse jeito
uma vez minha mãe falou assim ah poxa eu
vou partir dessa vida e eu não queria
ver você
desse jeito né e aí ela começava a
chorar foi e aí eu falei poxa preciso
mudar
então eu decidi que eu queria ajuda
só que como toda pessoa sempre tem os
seus anjos da guarda eu tive seis
mulheres
uau alguém pode falar qual é um homem
que teve seis mulheres aí a ninguém só
eu também tive seis mulheres fantásticas
na minha vida que me inspiraram que
fizeram a diferença na minha trajetória
na minha mudança e primeiro a minha mãe
queria contar um pouquinho sobre cada
coisinha dela de cada uma delas
então minha mãe foi o que me deu amor
que acreditou em mim e falou é possível
mudar se vai mudar porque você é um
leque muito carismáticos e tem a amizade
de todo mundo
segundo foi a dona andréia aonde e
quando aconteceu essa situação comigo da
paulada eu fui procurar eu sempre
admirei a aids grafite e aí eu entrei
nesse no curso pra pra tela de pintura
em tela e aí lá era um curso para jovens
- que cumpre medida sócio-educativa
ainda andré ficou com medo falou pô
aí o felipe me convidou para ir lá
formando agora foi o tal phillip e um
negão é que a gente faz agora e o
pessoal não queria abrir a porta do céu
pouco medo abri a porta não fez uma das
coisas mais fantásticas que eu admiro
nela ela me deu oportunidade ela não
entra aí faz o curso e toca aí e aí
falei beleza continue fiquei três anos
lá
depois me mandaram para a fundação de
itu onde eu fiz curso de contação de
história
depois de ana paula também trabalhava lá
que ela me ajudou
ana paula é pedagoga e ela me ajudou a
falar os nãos que nós precisa aprender
na vida e muitas vezes quando eu ia usar
droga nunca falava não fui eu tenho um
pingo de cocaína vamos lá vou eu pensei
que ela ia aparecer uma marionete
então ela você precisa falar não a
partir de hoje você precisa falar não
e aí eu aprendi a falar ou não a dona
aida luiz que me adotou como filho dela
é ela foi a pessoa que falou 'vai lá
trabalhar na minha escola tá eu quero
você lado ela tinha visto uma história
ela me acolheu e me ajudou muito na
segunda mãe e por último a minha esposa
elisa oa com a lataria feira 10
11 a morena vai pensando que não tem
idéia para trocar e aí consegui conhece
elise ela passava na viela foi morena
tudo bem e ela falou aqui esse cara que
é comigo e eu sempre mexi com ela até
que um dia falei mexer não está dando
certo
aí eu peguei e falei assim você sabia
que eu faço um projeto
aí ela deu ideia era colocar agora e aí
com tudo isso eu fui pra casa depois de
todos esses cursos que eu fiz eu preciso
criar um projeto que eu ajude essas
crianças a desenvolver alguma coisa
dentro do território e aí eu queria
contar uma história pra vocês que foi o
tem uma foto do cinema a gente um amigo
meu zinho e inventamos de fazer cinema
na viela chamava se inibe ela e dois
homens para organizar alguma coisa com
as crianças já sabe como é que é
organizam o tapete fizemos tudo para
deixar tudo organizado e cuidado das
crianças apareceu foi uma das que não
vai ser um fiasco é uma criança chegou
lá hoje o que estão fazendo aí senão a
gente vai fazer cinema pra vocês aí ele
falou é nossa que legal
vamos chamar os meus amigos e aí essa
criança ela revolucionou o nosso projeto
e aí veio de 80 crianças chegaram entre
adultos e crianças foi nós aqui da hora
e aí a gente começou a fazer cinema uma
vez por mês
e como eu fui um jogador de bola
frustrado né não tinha nenhum plano b na
minha vida tem esse jogador mas foi um
fiasco também agora vou treinar molecada
ser jogador de futebol
só que aí nos cursos que eu fiz qualquer
a minha ideia contar pegar um livro
conta a história para essas crianças
e aí depois a gente treinar no cinema
era fazer colocava o telão colocava tudo
contava a história
e também passava em cinema e eu peguei e
falei que não é que esse negócio é bom
as crianças adoravam que dia que vai ter
cinema que dia que vai ter futebol
e aí surge o projecto viela projeto
viela ele é uma organização social
cultural esportiva então todas as nossas
atividades
ela tem um pouquinho de esporte e todas
as atividades têm um pouquinho de
contação de história antes das nossas
atividades hoje nós atendemos 150
crianças
acho que é mais um porque o homem se
sabe como é que é a eles já chegaram a
dizer mais crianças sempre louco aí eu
falei mesmo neles são 150 criança hoje
nós estamos em 14 pessoas trabalhando é
inclusive tem o sogro o professor de jiu
jitsu está aí
quem levar comigo depois do ted aheta e
cuidado hein
o da então e aí a gente começou a fazer
uma grande revolução eu falei nossa acho
que esse é o meu propósito fazer então a
gente como a gente criou o projeto a
gente sabe que sempre surgem os talentos
naturais dentro da quebrada e um deles é
o carro a um jovem que foi campeão
brasileiro mundial e copa pode dígito
ele também veio também prestigiar e o
cauã ele deu super certo no esporte
porém o cauã não pode ser só as nossas
sessões
a gente não pode falar que o cauã é a
pessoa que tipo vai ter mais privilégio
de ver ela não
a gente tem que dar atenção também para
as outras crianças
então por que que a gente dá atenção
para outras crianças porque 99,9 por
cento tipo por cento dessa molecada
todos eles querem ser jogador de futebol
então 1% dá certo e aí falei poxa eles
são ea história dele é igual à minha
só passou o tempo eu falei então a gente
vai
vamos trabalhar com eles além deles a
quero ser jogador de futebol tudo bem
você vai ser um jogador de futebol mas
se o futebol não der certo você também a
gente também vai andar com você consome
da sua vida com aquilo que você quer
realizar o fórum futebol ea gente
precisava colocar na cabeça deles que o
futebol talvez não daria certo então
a gente tem a história do pedro que ele
se tornou músico eo pedro queria ser
jogador de futebol de qualquer jeito eu
falava pra dizer sabe não podia falar
pra ele que a estatística mostra que
você não pode ser jogador de futebol não
podia então falei 'então você vai
estudar e você vai dar certo em mãos
hoje o pedro é formado no auditório do
ibirapuera músico baixo elétrico baixo
acústico e toca todos os instrumentos
podem imaginar
e eu digo sempre que a mudança ela
começou em mim né eu fui buscar depois
que aconteceu tudo isso com a minha vida
eu fui buscar é outras fontes de de
idéias eu falei é preciso me ajudar
primeiros e ajudado fluiu então o
procurar ajuda estudei fiz um primeiro
semestre de faculdade e o projeto viela
ele me levou muito mais além daquilo que
eu pudesse imaginar o projeto e ela me
levou para portugal
o projeto vem ela me deu vários cursos e
aí hoje essa minha meta eu não quero
mais
como eu falei pra você a gente a gente
acha que a gente mora na favela a gente
tem que estudar e sair da favela não
hoje eu entendo que a favela um lugar
tão importante quanto qualquer outro
lugar do mundo e eu quero morar lá que
quero morrer lá quero viver eu quero
fazer as implementações que eu acho que
são corretas para aquele lugar
e aí eu queria terminar com a frase que
eu nunca ouvi ela na vida e criei ela
que toda criança tem o direito de
aprender brincando
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]